heroes it's an old-fashioned notion some  visionary from genius ensuring freedom  around the globe a symbol to the nation  a hero to the world  finding out across the stars  I look around the bus you're I see a  bunch of a-holes possibility  you think you know how the world works  the wound  is changing  we need  hero  I'll very strength  [Music]  in whites challenge  Challenge insights culture  culture  breathes catastrophe  the thing isn't beautiful because it  lasts  we're in the anger  before we're done  we still have one promise to keep  you can't protect the earth can be damn  sure we'll avenge it  whatever it takes  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]